la Inteligencia artificial tiene el
potencial de mejorar casi todos los
aspectos de nuestras vidas pero también
crea graves riesgos
Esas son las palabras de samantman el
jefe de la empresa Open hay que está
detrás de la aplicación
del senado estadounidense urgió por
regulaciones y pidió la cooperación de
los estados a nivel mundial para mitigar
los impactos de esta nueva tecnología
herramientas con mucha gpt han generado
temores sobre la capacidad de la
Inteligencia artificial de violar los
derechos de autor destruir puestos de
trabajo o crear noticias falsas un
escenario preocupante de Cara a las
próximas elecciones en Estados Unidos
es una de las áreas que más me preocupan
la capacidad más general de estos
modelos para manipular persuadir
proporcionar una especie de
desinformación interactiva uno a uno
por eso un grupo de expertos pide que
hay otras empresas pausen su desarrollo
de modelos más potentes durante seis
meses y así dar a la sociedad más tiempo
para considerar los riesgos también
necesitamos científicos independientes
no solo para que los científicos
tengamos voz sino para que podamos
participar directamente en el
tratamiento de los problemas y la
evaluación de las soluciones y no solo
después de que se lancen productos sino
antes Por el momento no hay indicios
inmediatos de que el congreso
estadounidense vaya a elaborar nuevas
normas sobre la Inteligencia artificial
como están haciendo los legisladores en
Europa